ready I'm system single fish
president/ceo exactly analogous and one
of the questions that was asked about
you is it important in Latin America for
the youth to participate to the economic
development of absolutely there is
nothing more important in getting the
youth engaged I would say that they use
and the next generation has to be
engaged not only in the economic success
of the countries and have to be engaged
politically in the political success of
the countries you know young people have
an opportunity to start in school by
going to school and learning and
becoming good science and technology and
having an appetite to learn
being entrepreneurial getting a job
because in growing economies like a
country like Brazil there are going to
be a lot of jobs available if people are
equipped for an educational perspective
so there is nothing more important
particularly in Latin America and other
emerging economies where the curve is
very skewed to you to getting youth
engaged economically and getting a
framework where the youth can find jobs
can get good job and the other thing
which is really important as I
encouraging to be entrepreneurs because
entrepreneurs when you're not to
preparing you are empowered to be what
you want to be to be who you want to
whom and to be successful and create a
better life for your children